i accidentally became a me and this is
that story i'm nick young aka swaggy p
dba star vh1 couples retreat star but
you may know me as this me
i don't mean happy
i would say this all started in the 90s
another kid watched home alone a lot i
always tried to do some of the stuff
around the house i was the baby so i
could get away with messing with my
brothers and not get in trouble you know
i had a way with getting them in trouble
if they hit me or i would act like they
hit me and just tell my mom they hit me
for they should get in trouble or i
would say if you don't do this i'ma tell
mom so i had a way of getting like kind
of what i wanted you know how i got into
basketball is because all my older
brothers they had to take me to the park
with them and that was like my
babysitters you know my mom said i made
my first shot when i was two years old i
don't know how she claims i did it on a
10 feet court like i was a super kid so
she said i was destined to play
adrian's pistachio
big meat my mom and his mom my best
friend so he was about 16 or 15
and he made a bet
on the court i guess we'll shoot threes
he always felt like he had a better
jumper than me i don't know why so he
did the best out of ten of course he
ended up moving he didn't think i was
gonna really make him run down the
street naked and i sure did i we got in
trouble for it because you know our
parents like why you make that boy right
out of street naked but they was
laughing at the same time because we
like we always been close he's like my
brother right how did i get into nba's
watching my closest brother that i could
talk to about everything once i seen him
getting on a shine in the family because
he was like the star player i was a
little jealous as a little brother and i
think that's going to spark me to try to
be better than him and get that shine
for my mom and dad like maybe all gather
up and go to his games and he was like
he could do the wrong but i was like man
i want that that's what sparked me to
play and ever since i just been
practicing hard working out and
making it l.a clippers the lakers
warriors the cassia female that's when
she first started off even just seeing
her around the gym she was taking
pictures for us and you know back then
before instagram and all that when you
get pictures she's like oh man these are
cool take more pictures of her and one
day she just asked me can i can i follow
you around you know i want to do
something new instead of taking pictures
i want to do like a video like a day of
life i was like okay i always wanted to
be in front of the camera so i let her
follow me around and lay things
me and adrian was doing that day
and you know going to my mom and dad
house you know mom's gonna be mum she
said something
if that boy ever take it serious he'll
be great
but he was a clown then
i didn't expect her to say that you know
moms don't normally call they smell
clowns you know you know it's better
words than that you know she could have
said you know so it kind of just caught
me off guard
hey well you know do that to me on
camera but it was funny yes the first
time i came to me was when world started
posting a tweet about a chapel escaping
prison and i came escape by my own house
and then i just started seeing people
tagging me and there was so many
different ones oh my god and i didn't
know what to expect first i didn't know
like really what was the mean about what
it wasn't and it just just took over
like some people don't know i played
basketball it was like ain't you that
mean guy i use your beam all the time
can i take a picture can you do the face
made it life of his own really i seen
the the teacher put the stickers my meme
sticker on the grave and papers that
that's funny i wish i could have made
some money off that
i made the meme hall of fame being a
jordan's cry face you know i feel good
about that i don't know that that would
be a question i asked
how you feel about your crying
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]